the opening scene features an obese
school girl named Jiang woo who has an
impressive drawing skill apart from this
we learn that Jang enjoys dancing
admires pop stars and has a particular
fondness for food she narrates that her
teachers and parents perceive her as a
lazy student with poor academic
performance and her friends see her as a
bully Target giang says that the main
reason she goes to school is to see her
Crush her handsome and intelligent
classmate goo Bay in order to get closer
to him she decides to run for a position
on the student council however it's not
that easy because jang's opponent in
this competition is Yu yi yi who is
pretty smart and popular XU is confident
to win the competition as she has done
in previous years during lunchtime she
shares a meal with her friend Jiang Min
and they are happy that XU is getting
many votes putting her in the lead just
then Jiang enters the cafeteria hoping
to gather some votes for herself but her
appeals fall on deaf ears shortly after
a mischievous boy steal seals her bag
and tosses it onto a tree making it
stuck on a branch he bets that everyone
in the class will vote for her if she
can retrieve her bag from the tree
though nervous at first giang summons
her courage and starts climbing the tree
she manages to get her bag but falls
down the tree while climbing down later
on XU checks the voting tally and
becomes infuriated to discover that Jang
now has more votes than she does
afterwards we see Jang struggling during
gym class clearly not enjoying physical
exercise after this she returns to her
classroom only to learn that Jang men's
purse has gone missing in response the
teacher permits jiangman to check all of
her classmates backpacks to jang's
surprise she discovers a pink wallet in
her own bag likely planted by someone
else soon after jiangman finds her
missing purse inside jang's bag as a
consequence the teacher takes Jang to
his office and punishes her by
disqualifying her from the election
after school Jang is walking home with a
disappointed face when she is approached
by an old woman this old woman appears
to know everything about jang's life
including the recent incident at school
much to our girl's astonishment the old
woman can read the inner thoughts going
on inside her mind this alerts Jang who
wonders if she is some kind of a ghost
in response the old lady waves her hand
over jang's face and advises her to go
home the following morning Jang awakens
and realizes that she's running late for
school she hurriedly prepares herself
and collects her belongings just before
leaving she notices a bracelet on her
desk intrigued she puts it on and
touches the Pearl at its Center the
bracelet then emits a blue light from
the top displaying a 24-hour countdown
timer on the screen unaware of the
changes brought about by the bracelet
giang exits her room and calls out to
her mother when she receives no response
she boards her bicycle and heads towards
School along the way she stops by a
street vendor from whom she buys
sandwiches every day but today the
vendor is also missing in the next scene
Jen arrives at school only to find the
entire building completely deserted she
Ventures to every class of the school
yet finds no one finally she realizes
that her dream has come true because she
always wanted to be away from everyone
either that or she got hit by a car she
then starts to enjoy the day doing
whatever she feels like initially she
spots Jang men's bicycle in the school's
parking lot and decides to hoist it to
the top of the basketball ring after
this she discovers a bucket filled with
red paint which she uses to paint on a
school wall if she'd done these things
before it would have made her popular
following these exploits she Cycles back
to the street vendor store and eats as
much food as she likes at last Chang
returns home and lays down in her bed
full and happy she eventually falls
asleep and her bracelet touches on a
Surface restoring things to their normal
State jang's mother then enters her room
to wake her up for school Jang checks
the clock and realizes that no time has
passed between the two Taps of the
bracelet she readies herself for school
and on on her way notices the street
vendor appearing distressed about his
missing food believing it to be a
coincidence she proceeds to school only
to find Jang Min along with her bicycle
stuck on the basketball ring moreover
the wall she had painted remains
unchanged unable to digest this reality
giang returns home and tries to explain
the situation to her mother however the
latter dismisses her words prompting her
to walk away sadly upon entering her
room Jang is taken a back to find the
same old lady eating her hidden stash of
food she asks how she got inside but the
old woman sidesteps her questions and
proceeds to explain the bracelets
extraordinary capabilities according to
the old lady the bracelet allows her to
have one extra day every week it
manipulates time enabling the wearer to
have an eighth day of the week once it's
activated the wearer is transported to
another dimension where they can do
whatever they want furthermore the lady
informs Jang that every action she takes
in this Dimension has consequences that
Ripple into the real world now that Jang
knows how to use the bracelet she
follows goo to his home using the
bracelet she sneaks into his room and
looks around the place it is at this
moment when she devises a plan and
writes a note for him she refers to
herself as pie From Another Dimension
and invites him to be her friend
couldn't have come up with a creepier
Icebreaker if I'd tried as the time
restores goo returns home and finds the
note on his desk perplexed he asks his
mother if anyone enters his room to
which she replies in the negative in
response goo pens another note seeking
further information about piie Jang once
again uses the bracelets power comes to
his room and writes a response in this
way they spend some time communicating
with each other apart from this Jang
puts her bracelet in good use for the
common good of the students she stops
time to tamper with certain school
documents related to holidays extending
the break to 10 days during an
interschool football competition goo's
team are on the verge of losing as the
opp opponent team scores three goals
Jang who is watching this from a
distance feels bad for goo as a result
she intervenes by freezing time and
repositioning the ball close to the
opponent's goal post enabling goo and
his team to score several easy goals
even though that's not how Sports work
ultimately goo and his team secure a
victory with 11 goals later in the
locker room XU and Jiang men are
conversing about J's victory in the
election they talk about how they
planted the purse on jiang's bag and
framed her is a thief our girl overhears
this conversation from one of the locker
rooms and decides to exact Revenge she
pauses time gathers all of her
classmates wallets and stuffs them into
zuu and Jang men's bags she then exits
the classroom and restores time to its
normal flow now the entire class
considers them thieves just as Jang
wanted now no one trusts any of the
politicians as it should be the scene
then cuts to the day of the exam in the
final 10 minutes Jang uses her ability
to stop time and copies the answers from
all the classmates answer sheets this
leads her to top the exam earning the
admiration of both her teachers and
Friends juu becomes envious due to the
special attention Jang is receiving
lately her frustration intensifies when
she observes goo engaging in sketching
activities with Jang after class in the
midst of all this Jang and guo continue
to chat via sticky notes one day they
are communicating in the library when
goo expresses his wish to meet her in
person I want to know who's breaking
into my room like every day Jiang
doesn't have enough courage to reveal
herself which causes her to stop the
communication leaving goo to wait
shortly after one of their classmates
approaches goo with a math problem when
he is unable to solve it the classmate
seeks jang's help who is also present in
the library however she has no idea
about it so she freezes time and runs
towards the teacher's office to find the
answers she somehow manages to find and
copy the answer before presenting it to
the classmate just then another student
approaches Jang with a chemistry problem
and once again she uses the time tactic
to find the answer eventually a growing
number of students gather around Jang
seeking her assistance overwhelmed by
the sudden surge of demand Jiang runs
away from the scene several days later
XU and Jang men are in a restaurant
discussing jang's sudden improvements as
they delve into their conversation they
begin to suspect that something might be
a Miss with jang's bracelet on the other
hand Jiang summons her courage and
agrees to meet guo in person filled with
excitement he inquires about how he will
recognize her to which Jang responds
that she'll be wearing a white dress
following this decision Jang visits a
clothing store to buy a dress for the
occasion when she finds out that she
cannot afford it she uses her bracelet
to steal the dress the following school
day zuu picks gang's locker and steals
her bracelet she tries it on her wrist
but nothing happens during the break zuu
goes to the classroom and rummages
through jang's Bag doing so she
discovers a notebook filled with sticky
notes from which she deduces that the
the bracelet only functions for Jang
since they can't do anything with it XU
and jiangman throw the bracelet in the
trash in the meantime Jang frantically
searches for her missing bracelet
growing increasingly anxious the next
day the class conducts another exam but
this time Jang doesn't have a bracelet
to help her left with no choice she opts
to cheat the exam only to be caught by a
supervisor after this the school
administration summons her mother to
complain about her behavior to make the
matter worse the shopkeeper from the
clothing store arrives at school to
return jang's notebook which she left
earlier simultaneously jang's mother
finds a dress in her bag which the
shopkeeper instantly recognizes her
behavior leaves her mother so enraged
that she slaps her in front of everyone
XU and jiangman Eaves drop on their
conversation and spread the news to the
entire School creating a hot topic for
the students to gossip about feeling
humiliated giang grabs her bag and runs
away in the next scene Jang wanders
aimlessly along empty streets venting
her anger by shattering glass bottles
after a brief while she is lucky enough
to locate her bracelet she puts it back
on and enters an abandoned warehouse to
spend the night there meanwhile her
mother gets very worried about her
missing daughter she looks for her
everywhere but to no avail the following
day Jiang remembers her planned meeting
with goo and hurries to their designated
rendevu point however her heart sinks as
she Witnesses XU is already there taking
her place she is wearing a white dress
and recites some of J notes convincing
goo that she's the one with whom he had
been communicating he immediately sends
her to jail for breaking and entering 25
times no that's not true from that day
onwards that dishearten Jang begins
living alone in the warehouse gaining
more and more weight a year later Jang
is approached by the same old woman who
asks why she's living such a miserable
life fearfully Jang confides in the
woman acknowledging her past wrongdoings
she also wishes to return home but she
can't dare to face her mother mother
sensing her sorrow the old woman
explains that she can solve some of her
problems but she cannot erase people's
memories therefore Jang will have to
confront her problems by herself and
move forward following this the old lady
erases something from her diary which
resolves the conflicts between Jang and
her mother finally Jang returns home
where we can see an emotional reunion of
the mother and daughter starting the
next day Jang returns to school but she
is still hated by her classmates
nevertheless she is determined to change
and improve herself she throws all of
her hidden snacks in the trash and
dedicates her extra time to exercise and
study in the midst of this process she
also visits gob's room where she
discovers a wall full of sticky notes in
these notes guo apologizes to pie for
failing to recognize that zuu is not her
this deeply moves Jang but she takes it
as a motivational factor to work even
harder after several months of hard work
Jang loses a significant amount of
weight and also excels academically now
ready to meet goo Bay she writes him a
note revealing everything about herself
she also apologizes for disappearing for
a long time and keeping him waiting she
then visits goo's house to deliver the
note only to find another note left by
him on his desk as she reads it she
learns that goo is returning to his
hometown upon learning this she uses her
bracelet to freeze time and hurriedly
rushes towards the train station a
couple of hours later her bracelet runs
out of time and her bicycle also breaks
down despite these obstacles she doesn't
give up and continues running toward the
station by the time Jang arrives goo's
train starts moving she frantically
searches every window of the departing
train and eventually manages to locate
him wasting no time she signals that she
is piie whom he has been speaking with
when he's unable to understand she
writes a confession on the platform
floor which leaves him in shock however
they're unable to react as the train
sets off in the final scene giang meets
the old woman who is trying to help a
young fat boy she hands over the
bracelet to the woman saying that it is
time for it to find a new owner now that
it has completely failed her in every
way subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching